hey guys Greg knuckles here back with
the 11th I think installment of the
string theory semi daily Q&A series and
today's question is in my opinion what
are some of the biggest gaps facing
exercise in sports science right now in
the scientific literature so there are
just right off the top of my head two
Biggie's that come to mind the first
would be that we don't have all that
much really really long-term data and
the second is that we have a lot of data
about you know factors that are going to
be better for most people most of the
time on average but not all that much
work has been done about how to optimize
a training program for the individual so
the first issue the fact that we don't
have just a ton of long-term data this
isn't something that I hold against the
scientific community at all because work
like that it's it's incredibly expensive
and unwieldy to do so there are a lot of
studies looking to see you know what
produces the best results over six weeks
eight weeks 12 weeks 16 weeks sum all
the way out to 20 weeks and you know
that's a pretty decent chunk of time
like that's going to be a training cycle
or longer for for most people you know
there may be some Olympic athletes
watching this on a quadrennial plan but
for most of us you know we're only
planning training 12 16 weeks in advance
most of the time so that is you know
that that is very good helpful data on
that time scale but something to keep in
mind is that most of the studies are
maxing out at 12 to 16 weeks or so so
that makes it difficult to say with just
a ton of confidence that one that one
approach is going to produce a lot
better results than another approach
over you know two three five ten years
it very well could be that something
produces really quick results in the
short term and then the results kind of
peter out whereas something
produces kind of more moderate results
over a longer period of time and so
there very well may not be meaningful
long term differences between those two
different approaches that's just
something that's that we can't really
say with a ton of confidence right now
just because there aren't many you know
two three four year training studies
being done that would be one incredibly
hard to recruit people for say like hey
turn your training over to me for the
next half a decade most people are going
to do that - it's gonna be a really
expensive study to run and then three
it's just gonna be a huge pain in the
ass so there's not a ton of stuff out
there like that right now which does
which does limit the timescales that we
can speak confidently on science is
really really good at sports science
exercise science at this point telling
us what's probably going to work well
you know over the next three or four
months but then past that straight up we
are just kind of extrapolating from
there and then the second issue that
there's a ton of data about what
produces superior results on average for
most people most of the time but not all
that much about how to individualize a
training plan so the way science
typically works in this field is you'll
have one group on one exercise plan one
group on another exercise plan and
typically from a control group as well
doing nothing and then you know after
three or four months of training you see
which one of those protocols produced
better results on average so you're
taking mean standard deviations most
research still works with p-value so a
frequentist statistical approach to see
at a pea level of less than 0.05 which
one of these produce better results so
that's that's how most research is done
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
the protocol that one out is going to be
better for everyone it just produces on
average the best results there is some
work being done there was a study by
even and a more recent one blanking on
the researchers name maybe Brown
I'll link them in the description but
yeah there is some research being done
showing well I guess kind of validating
that you know simply put some things
work better for for some people than
other people what may be kind of the
optimal thing based on our current
scientific understanding that's probably
going to produce good results for the
majority of people but it may be very
inappropriate for some people whereas
something that may not be as
scientifically validated may very well
produce better results for a minority of
people and there's there's very very
little work in that area being done thus
far and again that's that's primarily a
logistical problem as well because to do
that type of research you would need
crossover studies so you would need two
groups group one does protocol a group
two does protocol be four twelve sixteen
weeks whatever then have a pretty
lengthy washout period in between and
then group one does protocol B through
to does protocol a and then kind of
tease out what factors separated the
people who did best on protocol a versus
who did best on protocol be with
everyone doing both of the protocols at
some point during the study again those
studies they take twice as long to do
there gonna be more than twice as
expensive much harder to recruit people
for so again I I'm certainly not
begrudging the science at the community
for not having more of those types of
studies because yeah there would just be
a huge pain in the ass but to this point
there's an just not a ton of that type
of data to to really look at
individualizing approaches based on the
scientific literature and so really to
this point that's that's not an
incredibly huge drawback because with
what I've always recommended is using
the scientific data as a starting point
and then just personalizing your own
training program your clients training
programs from there
based on how they're responding to it so
at this point you know training yourself
or training other people it is just as
much of an art as a science so you know
you have that starting point you can get
that from science but then personalizing
it that's going to have to come from you
and your own experiences and you know
how you're responding to your training
how your clients are responding to their
training so yeah as I see it those are
right now the two biggest gaps in the
scientific literature for people trying
to use a very very purely scientific
approach to planning their own training
they're planning their clients training
and again neither neither one of those
things are things that I hold against
the scientific community at all because
getting that type of data would be very
expensive and very laborious but as it
stands now those are I think the two the
two biggest issues so you know for for
at least a while there's going to be
plenty plenty of space for lifters
coaches you know to apply their own
experiences on top of the scientific
literature to you know really optimize
training for yourself for your clients
so that is the video if you liked it
please like and subscribe and if you
have a question you want answered ask it
in the comments below and if it is my
favorite I will answer it in that next
video alright until next time guys hope
you have a good day hope your training
is good and I'll see you in the next
video